police in canada have begun a manhunt
for two suspects after at least 10
people were stabbed to death in the
province of saskatchewan another 15
people were wounded in the incident the
victims were found in various locations
of the indigenous community of the james
smith cree nation as well as the nearby
village of weldon the suspects are
considered to be armed and dangerous and
police have set up checkpoints
the stabbing spree is one of the
deadliest acts of mass violence canada
has seen
canada's prime minister justin trudeau
has described the attack as horrific and
heartbreaking
let's talk now to louise lopez who's a
freelance journalist in vancouver canada
louise what's the latest on the manhunt
what do we know about the suspects
the main hunt is underway as we speak
today terry police say they're doing
everything they can to track down the
suspects keep in mind people in the
province of saskatchewan are still in
the early hours of monday so expect the
story to develop over the next 24 hours
saskatchewan and two other neighboring
provinces are under uh an emergency
alert today authorities are hunting for
two suspects
31 year old damian sanderson
and 30 year old miles sanderson despite
sharing the same last name police say
it's still unclear if the two are
actually related it's believed the two
suspects are traveling in a black car
which was last seen in the capital
regina just before noon local time on
sunday the direction of travel of the
suspect is unknown but police believe
they're still in regina they're asking
people there to be vigilant and to
shelter in place meaning they're being
asked to stay in their homes this comes
at a time when more than 30 000 people
are in the city for a football game that
happened on sunday and as you said
earlier canadian prime minister justin
trudeau put out a statement a few hours
ago vowing that those responsible for
today's attacks be fully brought to
justice terry
now we've got 10 people dead stabbed to
death apparently another 15 wounded have
police
said anything about a possible motive
for these stabbings
police say some of the victims were
likely targeted but others appear to
have been randomly attacked by the
suspects
just to recap this all started sunday
morning in the saskatchewan first nation
that's about 200 kilometers northeast of
the city of saskatoon police say
multiple people are stabbed there and
also in the nearby community of welding
of about 200 people as you can imagine
terry very tight-knit community
residents are shocked today
at least three people were airlifted to
a hospital in saskatoon others were
taken in ambulances to other local
hospitals
the situation in some of these hospitals
was so dire some had to call in more
staff to deal with the with the
emergency terror
luis this is truly horrific has has
canada seen a case of violence on this
scale before
well canada whoever is no strange to
incidents of mass violence just a little
over two years ago in the atlantic
province of nova scotia a gunman driving
a replica rcmp cruiser and wearing a
police uniform killed 22 people in a
shooting spree that lasted several hours
before he was tracked down and killed by
police
but uh still very shocking
indeed uh louise thank you very much for
filling us in there that was journalist
luiz lopez in vancouver
you